check out the things
[Music]
harold wallach
please
um is he expecting you
that depends
tell him i'm a busty blonde with a
business proposition
and i guess we'll see
[Music]
if you'd like i can go back there myself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you an actress you're reading a
screenplay yeah it's for a show i'm in
or going to bed we're waiting for the
network to decide that's fun
i thought about writing a screenplay
once
about a scientist who creates a giant
bra that turns me into a genius who can
fight evil
cool
hi mr walk we'll see you now
good luck with your show thanks if you
believe that it can happen it will
and my old boyfriend used to handle all
the pictures but he is out of the
picture
and i don't even know where he got them
printed but he was super cheap and i
only want the best
so i grabbed the yellow pages i closed
my eyes and i said
find me the best printer in all the land
gods and fairies
you are the best right oh yeah yes of
course
gods and fairies right
we can do your posters of course
whoever did these use the four color
process so the pink doesn't really uh
pop out like it should you are so smart
harold
wow
thank you
uh
but uh look i i have to ask
what are you advertising oh these old
ones were for my band we're currently
looking for a new guitarist it's a long
story
the new ones will be just for me so
you're a singer i'm
[Music]
whatever you want me to be
okay
well right
we do posters for cigarettes and soda
and movies
uh so so
what are you advertising myself of
course
yourself
myself
you want to put up posters of yourself
just you around the city
yeah why not
nobody's ever done it why not start now
well i i'm not one to turn down business
but it's a very unorthodox idea but we
didn't need to send a man to the moon
that could also be thought of as an
unorthodox idea but we did it and it
inspired millions of people around the
globe maybe even the galaxy we don't
know yet i'm only interested in paving
new roads harold not following old ones
but if you'd rather follow an old one
that's okay and i'll find someone else
i never thought of it like that before
yeah this could be
brilliant
brilliant
it's a kind of avant-garde advertising
right here make one second honey like
you're making some
radical social statement now i'm not
sure what that statement is exactly but
maybe that's why it's so inspiring and
with your looks
and charisma perhaps we should think
bigger
i like that
perhaps much
bigger
imagine my face
here on a billboard looking over all of
hollywood imagine all this
for the entire world to see god yes and
and people will they'll look up and
wonder oh it'll drive them mad with the
curiosity they'll think who is this
woman because you're not a movie star
you're not a model you're just angeline
the billboard queen
[Laughter]
yes
yes ah
what's your budget
well i i don't have a budget
but if everything goes according to my
master plan i'll be the most adored
celebrity in the universe by 1989.
i'll be the best investment you ever
made harold
you